so I started this thing Kenneth in his
Bureau is Chinese worded of a speaker's
bureau but we provide advanced the
service like identifying the best
thinkers bring them to China funding the
best declined to host them provide them
with decent pay from 10k to 100k US
dollars and of course we help them to
localize them because we've been working
with like 500 or 300 bands the channel
local partners and clients so we are
able to fund each question sinker a
great host to disseminate their ideas
philosophies their love and their
experience in China know someone's
opinion may contradict yours what is my
friend Alan it's all about your
perspective who are we and what is the
nature of this reality
[Music]
Nihao everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don sockin we are still on
site in the beautiful Beijing China we
are now going to be talking about
bringing the world's top thinkers to
China we have da Wei Li joining us on
the show I don't think that and thank
you for bringing me here thank you so
much for coming on our show I'm so
pumped for our conversation I'm very
grateful to jinxo for introducing us to
for those who don't know da ways
background he's the CEO of Tosh on Qi
aka China thinkers Bureau which is
bringing the world's top minds to China
for collaboration and you can find the
links in the bio below to San Shi net
also China thinkers Bureau calm and a
really great piece that was published on
them in all teka Asia okay
that way let's start things off with one
of our favorite questions to ask our
guests what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world that their I self
our word so talking about their so we
need to have a director right and the
direction our world of lasting broadly
we are getting much much nicer and
leave me hood camper is like even 10
years ago 100 years ago nearly 2,000
years ago
we have much advanced technology some of
the technology held ductile but most the
technology is improving our little life
standard and of course we are solving
the most urgent social problems like 20
30 years ago we faced like the liberal
issues like their productivity
challenges like I believe the word is
solving the pollutions
atenas you can see pigeons air is much
greater than five years ago so but to
sum up I think our word is directing to
a much greater better directions that's
my first a response to a question of
course every moon has this dark side so
in China we often have a grid seeing
that our future is brilliant but the
path to the future is challenging it's
not easy
so it requires manpower requires our
collective efforts so China and us and
any other species and any other
nationalities should work together and
marching on this load to a much better
future so that's the direction yes okay
so we have increasing flourishing that's
happening over time and it's very
evident with people getting themselves
out of poverty getting access to the
cutting-edge technologies getting access
to the information economy is getting
access to healthcare it's all this type
of stuff also you say that there is this
dark side that we have to be careful of
and this is challenging the road is
challenging and we have we're trying to
grow the tree out of the planet birth
from this yoke of Earth with as little
suffering as possible and as maximize
flourishing as possible what would you
say is a key principle that we need to
embody to make
sure that we stay on this light side
more and away from this dark side as we
build all these technologies key
principles of course yeah so I believe
Steve Jobs has a very good manifest so
the crossroad of liberal arts and the
technology i believe technology will
inspire Libra us but Libra us in other
word like philosophy means the love of
life or the love of truth should be
directing the technology not the other
way around
so we need fan out was the real question
was the real challenge before we develop
a very advanced technology so pretty
simple explanation is we have a great
sentence that we have a great venture
capitalist we have a great ecosystem in
Silicon Valley and of course in here in
Beijing Heidi and to mention but before
all the great things happen we should
have a philosophy which which indicate
the Brad future of where are we going so
I think the fear the principal back to
your question is we need a loving caring
philosophy to direct all the development
of technology and the flow of capital so
that's my answer
mm-hmm philosophy yes agreed this most
fundamental first principled question
what is the ultimate nature of our
reality what is the point of this human
experiment at point of this and how can
we bring our full selves forward into
the world our full gifts forward into
the world and how do we build technology
that has love embedded within it that
has a positive trajectory embedded
within it and doesn't leave it open to
malicious players and malevolent actors
that type of stuff I like that a lot
let's talk about who you were growing up
and how you got interested in what you
care about today where were you born
tell us about your journey yeah I I was
I'm a great example of how globalization
education technology with the changes
one life so I was born in the Inner
Mongolia a very remote place in China so
that's like 40 years ago so 40 yeah I'm
a 40 40 years old today this year so
back that time China my hometown - Silla
is a very remote place compared with
Beijing but I've been my father provided
me a K to the library so I read a lot
even today so China and Beijing and
Silicon Valley is much at once the place
come here is my hometown today but I
read the same book like the people in
their 40s in Silicon Valley and I really
similar books like the people growing up
in advanced city huge city like
preaching so I believe knowledge is
rough my first stepping stone then why
I'm in my twenty something my father
provided me a opportunity to study
abroad so I've been to Britain UK for
like ten year study then that experience
make me a very internationalized
globalized the thinker people and
gradually I back to China like 10 or 20
tell 15 years ago about China after my
study in Britain so I joined I proudly
joined a very good organization called
accession media and of course I working
at a DRC it's a research thing that has
understood consult with the top people
of China best economists policymakers of
China Saudi gradually told me the was
the real was it happening in China and
was different between China and Western
philosophy and the theories so I have a
good youth parents and studying Western
world and I have a good knowledge and
grasp in China so I'm able to comment
those together to start my
entrepreneurship like three years ago
three years ago
I found out that Western thinkers great
thinkers have a market in China which
means deeper sell there are not only
books but of course ideas speeches
speech and product and
company whatever in China so I start up
this is think anything has Bureau is
Chinese word enough a speaker's bureau
but we provide advance the surveys like
identifying the best thinkers bring them
to China funding the best declined to
host them provide them with decent pay
from 10k to 100k US dollars and of
course we help them to localize them
because we've been working with like 500
or 300 bands the channel local partners
and clients so we are able to fund each
western singer a great host
to disseminate their ideas philosophies
their love and their experience in China
so that is my life journey but I want to
mention something to you before
candidate updates each period time of my
life I used to have a Idol or example or
someone to learn from this year and the
truth are 18 are learning from great
Chris Evans the actor of Captain America
so I learned how to go to gym with him
like him and a bureau of my body like if
you see my future five years ago I was a
totally fact bored glass awaring
mirror age losers but now I'm I'm
gradually went to gym and make myself
look like a Captain America and also
allowed portrayed his spirit the caring
spirit and leadership from him so make
me a better entrepreneurship so that's
my story
this such beautiful story okay so from
Inner Mongolia you had the access to the
library when you were young you had this
drive to read you had your father had
decided to help provide you with an
opportunity to go to study in the United
Kingdom and so then you go at around 15
age 18 18 you want an 18 and you came
back when you were about 28 that is
something great okay so you're there 10
years yes studying in the UK so you get
more deeply immersed in a
Louisville ization like you said and
which is actually really interesting
because it gives you a really unique
lens on the world growing up in
different cultures and then seeing what
it's like as London's a very big melting
pot of different cultures so you get
access to that and you get access to
Beijing and growing and coming back here
and and being able to do business here
and it's interesting like this helps
your worldview advance and become more
robust and well-rounded so then when you
come back here it's working with a lot
of the top economists and thinkers in
China and identifying what policies are
different from in China compared to like
the Western world and seeing those
differences and some similarities and
what could be advanced the the thinker's
Bureau work directly with advancing
actual policy in China is that yeah no
no no policy wise its I working with the
business world only okay so it would be
advancing business success in practice
yeah this is practices so then what
would be some of the things let's take
it here we'll start with this and then
we'll get to the I'm trying to think
Chris Bureau so what would be some of
those best of business practices that
you were working on what the think tank
that would advance the Chinese
businesses one good example is I'm so
honored and lucky to work with dr.
mister Piero scruffy the author of a
short history of Silicon Valley and many
other like hundred books so he's a good
singer he knows eras in Silicon Valley
he knows all the great restaurant in
Silicon Valley
although he's a vegetarian so like five
years ago China east of China like 200
tons trying to become the local version
of Silicon Valley
so the everybody want to become a
Silicon Valley but they do know how to
do it how to become a real civic man
anything oh let's build up a bring a
great University
so it could be our Stanford or let's
bring like 200 BC capitalist
venture capitalists so there could be
our Sakura but in fact that's not real
Silicon Valley Silicon Valley is based
on ecosystem so I'm honored and lucky to
work with mr. Pierre scruffy bring him
to China to speaking at a Beijing
Shanghai Shenzhen Ningbo Hangzhou turn
to hand like 20 top cities to tell the
local people what that real Silicon
Valley is how can we will help your
local version of Silicon Valley so
gradually after three four years so all
the Chinese people especially the
decision maker the business persons
knows what is the Silicon Valley how to
build up their own Silicon Valley and
how to how not to become a just
duplication stupid cop kind of in
Silicon Valley so I believe that helps a
lot
for local cities developers to become a
better version of themselves rather than
a better duplicate of a Silicon Valley I
think better is a good example
also I'm honored to work with dr. mr.
dick foster Richard foster a innovation
group
he used to started working in McKinsey
for like 35 years he is a global
authority of innovation so China has
been enhancing this in a regional
entrepreneurship national policy for six
years since 2013 but a very little
people know what how can innovation help
a nation innovation we think it's about
moving the heart moving or making up a
new dish cuisine how innovation help our
business our national competitiveness so
I prin
I was lucky to work with the dr. richard
Foster
bring him to China to talk to speak to
our decision makers maybe five or six
the provincial governors deputy
governors sit him ears and reprint his
1986 classic book innovation do Decker's
advantage in China sell like 10,000
copies and ask him to write up columns
teaching people how to use innovation as
business weapon so by working wisdom mr.
dick foster Genesis knowledge should
improve their ability to innovate a
little bit at least 101 percent I
believe so those are two examples
working with Silicon Valley people
working with innovation gurus helping
Chinese business and economic people to
improve their ability that is one of 12
200 cases I believe now there is a
really clear practice that you use the
practices that you identify top world
strategies for innovation and growth and
then you find them and you invite them
to come and and teach and I really like
how you talk about how it's about having
an ecosystem that's driving like what
Silicon Valley had and also like about
having these different ideas for recipes
for innovation and growth and then being
able to take those and spread them
around the top Chinese cities and then
have them actually get implemented into
business practices as soon as possible
this is great so okay so then about
three years ago you decided that you
wanted to start to Sean Shay trying to
thinkers bureau and you have now these
speakers coming and they get like ten
thousand to a hundred thousand US
dollars they're coming to China there's
going on speaking tours they have really
good hosts really good immersion into
culture build really good networks and
collaboration so there's like a
long-term collaboration happening
between some of the ideas that they have
and some of the ways they can be
implemented in China is that about right
yeah sure okay and then now like walk us
through then is is is the example that
you gave where someone's coming and
they're going on a tour across the major
Chinese cities and speaking to you know
maybe hundreds of people out of time
about the ideas and about how to
implement them is that generally what
China synchro's viewer is doing
primarily yeah
to all the business oriented people as I
mentioned I also so proudly the work
with like 20 Nobel laureate bring them
to speak economics and innovation at
occasions as well okay so also Nobel
laureates coming across different
Sciences and innovations education and
so then they come and teach as well so
it's both like authors leading thinkers
corporate owners as well as Nobel
laureates are coming here and doing this
it's mostly speaking tours across
China's output and speaking tours and
collaborations with local leaders in
those areas yeah to advance business
policies and here's - yeah okay okay
cool cool now let's take us through an
idea of what you foresee being like the
best model for this because we have we
have you know the United States and
China is so important for the - to
collaborate and work more harmoniously
together moving forward we have many of
the other world leading economies that
we also want to in a sense we want to
help take good ideas from them and
implement them in our countries that
have good ideas from us I would get
exported to their countries how do we
best make a global collaborative social
fabric more effective mm-hmm that's a
beautiful question firstly I'm a
question in this question why should we
have a global as a fabric society we
don't have to so China has their own
requirement and once so you see the top
10 global thinker in China maybe are not
top 10 global thinkers in states there
is only one simplest line you are re he
is like top 10 fingers in states and top
10 singer in China but the rest now are
different so we do not have to have a
unified fabric fabric society that's my
answer to your question
my challenge focus but also I believe
there are few approaches are great why
is the global summit and
conferences like the Davos this year
there are four five thousand people meet
here Davos attending hundred events
conferences using their ideas making
connections that's one thing good and I
know there are many other career events
like the leg pad PD went like the
Burning Man like a thousand best off
those come with conferences the physical
meetings provided to the people from
different world would definitely improve
their understanding of each other that's
number one number two I guess that also
the future is by the young people like
in their teenagers twenty years old
people arcade used to working on a
online society so we have like wheeshing
Weibo it's the Chinese the world of
Twitter but let's think about it maybe
in the long term from now the future
there is the technology could combine
Twitter and we were together so the
people in Webre would see what happening
twitter twitter will see we bruh I mean
all the technology platforms if they
work together would provide a huge
virtual reality for the real people
improve their understanding and improve
their beliefs and would have probably
helping the harmonious society as you
mentioned so physical meetings and
technology mm-hmm you're coming back to
the very first thing you're saying there
may have been like a miscommunication
with the way that I said the question or
something just because the way you
answered it is actually in the way that
I was thinking about it as well which is
that you have different world leaders
world thinkers in China versus Saudi
Arabia versus Russia versus Korea versus
the United States blah blah blah and so
ideally what I was thinking is it would
be great to see if there was a way to
take the ones in the US and bring them
to Brazil or Korea or whatever and have
the ones in Portugal and South Africa go
to China or go to what other could what
tile and whatever other countries around
the world basically make a greater
social fabric around exchanging world
top thinkers and ideas and then having
go and speak and share it so that it can
advance business practices in advance
that type of stuff and it seemed like
that was kind of also something that
that you were feeling when you were
answering the question so seeing how we
can maximally get there fast is great I
actually also really liked what you said
about Weibo and Twitter because it in a
sense it's like how do you connect like
a billion people here with a billion
people here that are using a very
similar social media communication
platform but that currently can't talk
to each other across that social media
gap and so that's also kind of like
WeChat and whatsapp or Facebook
Messenger or whatever you want to say so
I also really like that one too because
there seems to be a serious amount of of
hindrance of creative endeavoring when I
can't as easily communicate I can't as
easily share I can't as easily co-create
with someone else because of this gap
between the platforms so how can we in a
sense take the silos that are the
platforms and make some sort of a
communicative fabric across them so we
can become more creative together
there's a very big question and you
brought this up so I want to I want to
ask it do you feel like the role of
exponential technologies you mentioned
something like a virtual reality you
know a lot of people from around the
world starting to be location agnostic
meaning that don't need to be strapped
into being in in Beijing being in their
office but they can work from home they
can go work from somewhere else in the
world etc they can just go into the VR
environment and work with other people
from around the world from their home
etc you know that being one of many
there's so many other things about
genetically engineering away diseases
and genetically augmenting ourselves or
using neuro technology to augment
ourselves there's so many of these
up-and-coming
that are quantum computing being
unleashed into the world
so with given all these exponential
technologies and given our our mutual
desire to to take the best practices
from around the world and bring them
forth into all of the different
countries practices what would you say
then is a way that the of those
exponential technologies that we listed
earlier plus the sharing ideas around
the world how can those two things
synchronize and interplay most
effectively synchronize the mutual
technology and I think a very little
about that because probably those are
the ideas only generated from the smart
people from Silicon Valley I believe the
99% of the people around what to do not
think about the question like that a
connectivity or whatever the only thing
about how this technology on this new
app would improve my business are
helping me to get more food and her
salary so there is a question where are
the avant-garde very advanced but
doesn't solve the real challenge an
issue of our society the real challenge
the issue are the lower productivity
lower wages have a heavy load either
works and like in China the 99% not
China I mean globally is the speaking
ninety percent of people do not have the
access to air technology don't have to
they don't need that so my upon is your
question is a great one but I don't have
the answer but comments on your question
is that it is it's not very it's not
very important to question from now it's
a elite question so the real challenge
for 90% of world population is how can
they use technology improve their work
life and maybe leaving standard
interesting so all those exponential
technologies that we listed do exactly
that they help take people out of
poverty they help give them access to
more money more food more water more
shelter all these basic needs healthcare
etc so the democratization of those
technologies could be one of those
business practices we were talking about
earlier where people can more
effectively distribute the technology to
more people faster and take them out of
poverty increase their living standards
etc so even though the question itself
may seem like in a way it's like elite
in a sense at the same time the
practices that can be implemented from
the distribution and the dissemination
of the technologies and the
democratization of them is exactly what
gives 90% of the world the advancement
of money of getting out of poverty
getting more healthcare at that type of
stuff so that's kind of why I guess I
ask the question is like what best
business practices can help take the
cutting-edge technologies and
disseminate them democratize them to
more people around the world to get them
out of poverty faster and get them
advanced faster I think this is very
complicated question and instead a man's
giving you a very complicated answer we
can look at a several great practice
good examples wanted to show me you know
Steve Jobs invented this beautiful
iPhone like 10 years ago it's beautiful
but they're productively only can
provide like 1% of the better future
people around the world to use iPhone
the iPod is very expensive iPhone but
show me even to the similar quality
phones and of course far away and some
of the Chinese mobile producer
manufacture can provide the lists that
develop the people that the poorest
people in China
Oh see very underdeveloped and nations
like those African countries to use the
similar phones like Silicon Valley
people using with 10% of their price so
my opponent is show me in hallway are to
increase job by
disseminating that advanced technology
to a poor people larger populations so
we should have instead of giving a brief
answer we should look at what a ShowMe
is doing I believe that is a great
democratization of Technology instead of
we're going on the street teaching
people what are they I mean was there is
the challenge with the ethnic issues of
AI we could we could use some $120 by
two smart speaker it's the cheapest AR
terminal anywhere in the world is a bad
word speaker just give to a where poor
people ask them I told them you can ask
whether you can ask everything from this
speaker if you are feeling lonely and
bored you can ask the speaker play music
and standing comedians and whatever to
you it's only cause you like one sins
per day nearly nothing so instead of the
assembly the other stuff is killing the
philosophies which Silicon Valley pew
allowed to do we just provide a very
cheap things to the poor people
yeah that is better prose I guess this
is a really good example okay
such a good answer okay so we have so
many things that Silicon Valley's doing
and I'm actually deeply critical of this
as well because a lot of what the
technologies that are being made out
there are for the 1% of people that can
afford a 1,000 plus dollar phone or a
2,000 plus dollar computer or want some
sort of a way to augment you know their
$50,000 Tesla or their their their their
augmenting incrementally instead of
doing something like what you gave this
example will show me where they're doing
something like making the their their
their hardware is come in it's
compatible it's
it's a but it's at the it's at a very
close level of competition
sophistication with a behemoth like
Apple selling it at a fraction of the
price to enable people in China and
other developing parts of the world to
gain access to information technology
being democratized at their fingertips
for less money
excellent another great example the
Baidu speaker we obviously have our
Amazon and Google and Apple ones as well
yeah we have our speakers as well and ok
so you take this Baidu speaker and you
called it an AI terminal I love that
right so instead of going around and
being like and being around hey hey
people around the world you should care
about AI ethics and you know and people
that are literally just trying to
incremental e improve their life they
have to now become leading AI Ephesus
and philosophers versus giving them a
Baidu speaker and giving that AI
terminal like you said ask about the
weather ask about education stuff ask to
enhance your mood after all this type of
stuff play music play games with friends
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah and
all of a sudden that person is becoming
more and more tied into what natural
language processing is what how that
object is working with the cloud
computation how that object is able to
on-demand do what I asked you to do and
so I think that becoming democratized is
actually a great way to get more people
to eventually end up caring more about
AI and to care more about technology
through their everyday use rather than
having some sort of highly sophisticated
philosopher that's telling them about AI
ethics so I think that's a really good
answer an example so it could then be
that some of the best business practices
are to figure out how to enhance the
life of
average people around the world
incrementally through education through
healthcare through technology through
science there are these types of things
yeah that's my point of view I like that
a lot mm-hmm
okay so let's let's play on this a
little bit more then so how does a China
thinkers Bureau how do you envision the
what we just said how do you envision
thinkers coming from around the world to
China and helping the different areas
incrementally improve these different
cities incrementally improve the living
standards mm-hmm yeah as you mentioned
we are living in a global and society so
not only Beijing there are 119 and other
cities in China as well especially we
have 200 cities some cities America
localized very well-informed some some
cities or see some companies or some
people need to learn what is happening
outside of my city and what is the best
practice in Beijing in ginger in Silicon
Valley in New York so what I'm happy is
a broad cage of talents and knowledge
bring those people to those least less
developed a city is like another 199
cities to talk to peach to preach I mean
what is happening in Silicon Valley in
New York in Beijing in Shenzhen the day
they might demand not to can start to
learning from or listening from speaker
but at least it's a good reminder to
them what is happening now helping them
to increase their efficiency and
effectiveness and with lower budget with
lower cost that would help not only the
cities in China but the overall benefit
of the Colombian society for example if
everybody in China we have 1.5 billion
Chinese people maybe 1,000 people
five years ago 1000 people knowing what
is the real city chronic so if you are
from Silicon Valley come to the rest of
China people seem you are strange
but after mr. Paris kulfi giving talks
in China maybe there are too many people
understand what is happening in Silicon
Valley so if you meet him is those Wow
of those 200 the two million peoples you
will have a common knowledge command
standing so dancing we improve the
efficiency of international corporation
and decrease the possibility of
conflicts so in the future my detailed
future is I bring maybe 100 200 greatest
thinkers speakers from Silicon Valley
from European countries from Israel from
Japan come to talk to China and I will
bring another maybe 20 to 10 in smart
people to talk in different countries I
love it will help the understanding of
each other
yes yes I love this vision this is very
aligned with what we care about with our
show that's why we're here in China
right now it's showcasing some of the
greatest minds here and so if we can do
a deeper collaboration where we can help
funnel some of the smartest minds into
what you're doing and if you guys will
come funnel some of the smartest minds
onto the show that could be super
interesting and it's a very interesting
alignment with with our passion I like
that I like that
what about this is a very this is this
is a I love this vision I'm just I'm a
huge huge fan of this vision it's very
geopolitical it's very it's very focused
on on best practices you like identify
what's best around the world from
different thinkers and you try and bring
that around the world to different
cities into different business
strategies around the world it saves
money it increases people's health and
education and it's just it's a
no-brainer and it's a good one I like it
I like it it's an easy one
the challenge is how to best get there
but it's a no-brainer vision the vision
is easy really important okay let's ask
about some of these more these questions
that are a little bit like you mentioned
earlier like we don't we sometimes
forget to ask the really big questions
and sometimes the really big questions
can get young kids to want to do
something that besides just being there
like little like bubble of their like
community but like go out and try and
tackle one of the big world challenges
like a sustainable development goal or
something which you also mentioned
earlier about China's push for
sustainability and all this type of
stuff so okay so let's talk about
exactly that this ultimate question of
what is the point of the human
experience what's the point of us
evolving on this planet orbiting the
star what's the point what's the meaning
of this I cannot give you a direct
answer but I can choose someone how to
solve this issue so the political
correct answer would be improved other's
awareness helping our Pro brothers
sisters and in fact this is a pasta
basket bucket ask them to think about
this question the meaning of life is
that your question
yes
[Laughter]
I don't know my favorite brand bad they
called Backstreet Boys uh-huh they have
a similar sound so we the meaning of
being lonely mission death and so many
meaning of being human right ha ha yeah
so if there is a political correctness
answer is the meaning of life is
improved over rock grid of our human
society having that other peoples to
improve our living food that's why you
are here in this world there's a desk
kept Americans answer but my answer is I
don't know I have to keep on living
probably the answer is act rather than a
phrase or a paragraph keep living do not
settle you know you know yeah I'm so on
improving other people's living
standards around the world I like that
ok yeah this is good yeah I like that
it's a it is it's it both helps
ourselves find something that gives us
passion to wake up in the morning with
and it also gets other people around the
world living better it's really good
you mentioned this earlier I think it's
important to come back to this idea that
you had about five years ago a little
bit less healthy you were a little bit
less healthy you started picking up some
better health habits some better
exercise habits this type of stuff I
think a lot of people around the world
are are wondering you know how can I
become healthier
what were the key things that you
decided to do to motivate yourself into
and create habits into creating a
healthier that way I think from thanks
to American culture and reverse this
movie Avengers and Captain America maybe
only the teenage boys in stays worse in
that movie but people like me in new
China I was crying
totally worship in there he stood a
heroic act so I want to become him
exactly like Kevin
Eric a tall handsome strong athletic no
glass more Harris and I helping the
endanger the nation of course as well so
I learn a lot from him so that is a
motivation to make me have a healthier
life to be more energetic to giving a
batterer endeavors to the society so
then what were some of the habits that
you started doing yeah I wouldn't to gym
more often and I had a private trainer
and I eat healthier and sleep earlier
and I go to yoga classes as well played
tennis couldn't swim basketball scores
all the sports yeah so sports make us
smarter yes I guess yes more energetic
yes so so to answer question a better I
mean the one the culture advantage
advantages culture would attract people
from different culture to study from him
then so my culture doesn't have a spirit
of people to Goose boss in Chinese
traditional culture a gentleman shoe
that do last sports probably just
maintain meditation or maintaining
steady life like a real gentleman but a
Western culture the athletic culture the
Greece culture I encourage people to
fight to work out I believe that is
great that's that's much more
constructive than any other ideologies
from Western world I mean leaving habit
mm-hmm yeah I agree
that's a really powerful one is this
pushed basically the aesthetics the
aesthetics of the human like get your
body looking pristinely like you know
that's yeah that's a very you think I'm
not perfect I have you you too brother
you look really good I love it
and like you know being 40 like that's
what's up like yeah you're doing really
well I like that a lot
okay and then how about as we go into
the exponential technology age young
children now have their whole lives on
the devices their entire life they don't
know what life is like without the
phones and computers what is a skill
that you think that young people should
know going into the future
the skill to go into the future I
believe Chinese people young people like
critical thinking is important critical
thinking yeah and thinking and looking
outside of the box is important if you
do not looking outside of both how can
you think of several box the people if
they're using their mobile phones their
tendency the only watching the
information the technology provided you
want to show them to miss the real the
real world so this will go out and
really Mobile's meeting more people
traveling a lot go to the place have no
signals out cool place just mobile for
easily to be stolen so you can go to the
real world
meeting real people China itself and USA
Reserve is already very diverse offense
society itself will provide more angles
and perspective for any individuals but
if you are fully equipped and you are
growing enough grown up enough you
should travel outside our nation and
meeting with the people from different
culture that's also important so
critical thinking to explore the unknown
territories territories important for
the younger generation I love that yeah
critical thinking also the exploration
of what it's like to not have a device
for a day and just be immersed in nature
be immersed in human eye to eye contact
and knowing how to have good social
dynamics and generals are really
important
yeah very important what do you think is
the role of love in our world
yeah love is the one of the reasons we
survive we live in this world so but
there are different levels of love the
small smaller level or the elementary
level is the love that
Travon by the hormones and biological
needs it's loving your wife your husband
your friends and also her level of love
is the curiosity anxiety or what is
happening then a new world you know that
is the law yes to having all the great
entrepreneurial as Steve Jobs great
philosophies and the greatest thinkers
economists I believe the reason you do
this is because allowed to explore
unknowns yeah but even greet allow that
at the top of the pyramid would be the
the long-term interest and the curiosity
of the human society human being so like
a religious law it's a religious tableau
so without any resolve the repair of any
feedbacks just devote yourself to
something great I believe the law Oh
three lovers lovers important but once
without love there
people cannot survive and throughout but
with love people are able to achieve
something great for the human society
and for itself
love it love of the unknowns and just
whether that unknown be a relationship
with the partner or whether that be
building something into the world of
great value
going into the chaos and then finding
some sort of order and going on this
journey of developing one's self I love
that and then what about do you feel
like we have free will do you think
things are determined what do you think
about that I'm a totally of a group is
Peter Thiel so he believed a freewheel
I believe freeware I think people can
chin and achieve what Herod they want
provided there is a great methodology of
course Rita Leo believe so so readily Oh
Peter Thiel an authority three great
thinkers of the world and you are a new
element we fall fast believe that free
will is is achievable what do you think
free we are no free meal this is a very
complicated question there's so many
variables it takes a long time to be
able to unpack many of these variables
you know your gut microbiome has been
around for billions of years and that's
just older than then you and your cortex
is and so it's just you know there's
that there's so many other aspects to it
just like we manipulate Drosophila fruit
flies and mice and fish and monkeys and
do tests on them there is very hubristic
it's overly self-confident to think that
there's not higher intelligence also
doing the same thing to manipulate us
and so there's lots of ways to take this
and there's lots of variables but it's
it's I think it is very good to believe
that we have some sort of a thing to
bring to the world and that we have to
wake up and bring that thing to the
world every day I think that's
incredibly important do you think that
given the rise of computational power
that we may be living in a simulation
yeah probably probably there are too
many years to go so the the people in
Silicon Valley they love to think about
this future world where we can utilize
that I know but if you go to a NASA if
you go to the rest of the world thing
see the 90% of the world nearly is not
water around is a mutation and
singularities know they need a cleaner
food they need a maybe Tennyson's
higher pay raise year our yeah so
probably there are some very smart
people will frozen their brain are
living in the interest in singularity
were but the majority I mean 1990-1999
personal people still struggling for
improve a little bit their traditional
way of living and that it will last like
two thousand years or maybe once all the
ninety nine hundred years so the
singularity and the simulation there and
just a lot [ __ ] the craft still field
Inklings so there's there's a there's
this there's this curve of ideas right
now let's say and and a lot of the very
edge ideas over here if they become more
about maybe how to improve the lives of
ninety nine percent of people then we
can advance society faster sometimes
then if you just have this sort of some
people call it like intellectual
masturbation around topics around like
oh if we're in a simulation or if we're
if we're approaching a singularity or
how many how long it's gonna take for us
to get there so I like I like questions
like that because they can expand the
mind but I also really like questions
that can help a vast majority of people
increase their living standards around
the world last question is what do you
think is the most beautiful thing in the
world most beautiful things in the world
I'll have to do you seventy Yosemite I
never been there but I believe you
certainly uh if you go to my Mac
computer the desktop the war people
would be you seventy most beautiful
world Wow I believe it's a world with a
man woman I echo and people are higher
paid less stressful everybody go to gym
and no poverty I think those are my
utopia utopia is my beauty most
beautiful place here yeah I'm not
another let me finish this and I believe
we are approaching to that building here
and the beauty is like a rabbit whenever
you catch it you a little bit close to
catch it up so there is a they will jump
to a higher distance there another
beauty exactly yeah yeah
the constant iteration towards the
pinnacle civilization and keep going
yeah yeah that is who that way this has
been such a fun episode thank you for
coming on our show thank you how is this
a simulation listen to my speakers here
oh yeah you just adjust speaker exactly
yeah I like that collaboration between
us let's definitely explore doing that
I'm really looking forward to that
mm-hmm also thank you everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on that episode let us
know what you're thinking also have more
conversations with your friends families
co-workers people online about how we
can bring some of the world's top
thinkers to different countries around
the world wherever you're watching from
how can you bring some of the world top
thinkers to your country to where you
live and to help increase the business
practices in your countries let's get
going let's bring the world closer
together and bring the best ideas around
the world like that look who is that it
you want to think as well thank you -
all right thank you thank you and for
all those also that want to take their
best thinkers around the world and bring
them to China go through Tashia a.net go
through china thinkers Bureau calm go
through and get in touch with that way
and let's have them come and do with
speaking tour in China so go through
fall through on that and support the
artists the entrepreneurs the leaders
around the world that you believe and
support them help them grow support us
simulation you can find all our links
below patreon cryptocurrency paypal you
can design cool merch and get paid all
those links are below and go and built
the future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we love you very much
thank you for tuning in and we'll see
you soon
peace bye bye so this is the piece yeah
that's it brother good job good job good
job now
so fun yeah that is beautiful beautiful
tour yep yeah that's how we do it huh
that's how we do it they're doing really
good job yeah I can like we have to clap
we have to figure out how to how to best
collaborate
[Music]
you
[Music]